so yeah today i'm going to talk to you
about
a b testing about things that are really
great about a b testing things that are
not so great about a b testing and how
to solve them and how to manage them um
when i was preparing my slides i kind of
checked their agenda for the conference
and i saw that a lot of the talks are
very machine learning engineering
tooling kind of focus so
if you are a machine learning engineer
and you think what does this have to do
with me i promise at the end or towards
the end i will tie it all together also
to uh problems in machine learning
engineering so stay put
like i said i'm gonna start talking
about a testing before that a quick
introduction of my employer that was so
gracious as to fly me here today um
and a little bit about myself um i'll
talk about why a b testing are so great
i'll talk about why they sometimes
aren't so great and what does that have
to do with machine learning
end up with some suggestions of what you
can do in order to kind of mediate a lot
of the problems and we'll have some time
for questions at the end
so a few words about my employer um just
by reserve hand how many of you have
heard about shopify before
okay good
because when i joined the company which
was a while ago i used to tell people
it's the largest company you've never
heard of
because the company basically provides
infrastructure for e-commerce so a lot
of the time all of you probably bought
something from a shopify merchants you
just never knew that you did because
we're in the background
basically powering everything from the
front-end back-end logistics all kinds
of integrations and different services
from finance fraud and basically
spanning the whole spectrum it's a large
company originally found in canada and
now operating without offices all over
the world so um i'll mention this at the
end we are hiring
a few words about myself so i'm a senior
data scientist at shopify i've been
working for almost 20 years now in a lot
of different industries
if you talk to me for more than five
minutes about anything that has to do
with machine learning or statistics you
will find very quickly that i'm in
bayesian i call it bayesian by belief
but
i do recognize that
a lot of the time
as data scientists the most important
machine learning algorithm we can
provide to the business is maybe the
average or a million because that if you
can answer the question in the right
time and impact business decisions uh
that has a lot of the time much more
impact than any
sophisticated deep reinforcement
reinforcement
model you can develop so that's
something i kind of hold very near and
dear to my heart um yeah in my free time
i do try to do a lot of sports even
though you can't really tell um
and i joined actually this year i
decided i'm going to find how exactly
how fit i am and join a very large
international competition it's called
the crossfit open
i think more than 200 000 people this
year and i discovered that i'm a very
very mediocre crossfitter
they provide a lot of data it's really
cool they don't tell you just good bad
they actually give you the exact
percentile so i know exactly where i'm
ranked which is not great but i think
finding out you're not great is also
something good to find out every once in
a while right
um
okay
so let's talk about av testing um i'm
assuming some prior knowledge that at
least all of you have heard about the
term a b test and you know what i'm
talking about um kind of in a nutshell
you've probably seen
a million times different versions of
this cycle
in a general kind of way we can talk
about first of all kind of figuring out
what you want to ask what's the question
what's the business question you want to
answer um next step will be to decide so
it can be something like we want to try
a new version of our recommendation
engine a new design for the website a
new product that we're offering if we're
in a fintech company and anything that
can you know anything you want to
basically test versus the existing uh
solution that you have
we then decide on what we want to test
kind of what we want to measure i would
say is it clicks is it money is it user
satisfaction or is it lifetime value
we then create two different versions or
n different versions we run the
different versions in production
collect the data measure the results and
decide which one kind of won the
competition right it's a very very
simple uh uh
concept
and it's a very effective concept now
just by reserve hand i'm not gonna
question you about this anybody here
kind of can tell me
why or can can answer the question why
do a b test work so well just by raise
the hand and if you don't want to
participate feel free it's fine
okay
i don't see a lot of hands up which is
fine also if you choose not to
participate
the reason kind of the core reason that
a b testing works so well
is because we randomize
if you want to compare two versions of a
website or two products or like i said
two recommendations and two
recommendation engines or whatever you
want to compare um you want to make sure
that the groups that got version a and
the group that got version b are
very similar to one another because if
for example for whatever reason we
divide our users into two group and one
group is actually over the age of 40 and
another group is under the age of 40
just as an example
um
we will have a problem because then
what can we say what can what can we say
about the impact of the new version did
it come from the product or did it come
from the fact that the users were older
or younger or anything else that might
happen here right so we want to compare
basically we want to make sure that the
only difference between the test group
and the control group is our what's
called our intervention that's the name
in in medicine
or basically is the test right we want
to make sure that that's the only
difference between the two groups and
randomization is actually a very good
way to do that
um
you can in theory if you know maybe not
a lot about your users you can kind of
divide them into different groups and
make sure manually to balance these
groups and that can also work as a form
of a b test but randomization gives you
a nice statistical guarantee that if you
randomize correctly your users or your
sessions or whatever else you're trying
to you know bank accounts or whatever
else you're trying to randomize here you
will end up with two groups that are
pretty much similar to one another
and by the way
if you know a lot about your users you
can and should test that every time you
run an a b test sometimes called an aa
test basically you just want to make
sure that your groups are actually you
you finished under my randomizing like i
said it's a statistical guarantee you
might end up sometimes actually with
groups that are very different and you
want to check that even before as you're
running your a b test
um that's great
if you know about you you know a lot
about the things that you're measuring
i'll be talking a lot about users or
buyers here but again you can generalize
this to anything else that you're
testing on
and it's great if you know a lot so i
don't know i've worked with in the
fintech industry and you know banks
usually know a lot about their customers
they have to know about it but if you
are in the e-commerce space and we're
talking about buyers or even visitors
we don't know a lot about them actually
we know less and less the more
regulation
tells us exactly what we can and cannot
know and the more we have tracking
blockers and all these kind of things
so you don't know a lot about your users
and this is the amazing part about
randomization and why every testing
works the way that it works is because
you don't just control for what you see
you also control for everything you
don't see
right if
we used to have this example we would
never know the eye color of the customer
we just never know that and maybe that
has some impact on the decision or in
the preferences we would never know that
but if you randomize at least we have
some guarantee that these two groups
should contain a good mix of eye colors
even if it's something that we never see
so
and another
honorable mention i would say um is the
fact that randomization also works
really well with streaming and with
complex data types so it's a really
really not convenient but really
efficient and great way of making sure
that your results are meaningful
now
let's look at a
interesting and like a quick example um
pet beds how many of you by the way have
a cat or a dog
okay
um so it's a nice thing you know a nice
thing to have if you have a cat or a dog
or any other animal that likes to sleep
in this kind of
in a bed
um and let's assume that we have in
january
beginning of the year
we the pm comes to us and they say okay
we want to test a new model or we want
to test a new configuration for our
website
for simplicity let's assume that's the
only thing we're selling different types
of pet pads
or maybe you want to test a new
recommendation engine against the
existing one
and we say okay
let's set everything up we set up the
randomization we uh run the test in
february as you can see results are
already improving because maybe 50 of
our users already got the new version so
we should see some changes to the
numbers um and at the end when we
conclude the experiment we discovered
that there's a five percent increase in
conversion rate amazing right that's
really good that's really good
everybody's happy let's launch let's put
the new version into production
come may things
not looking so great anymore and as we
get into summer things are actually
looking pretty bad and again let's
assume things are pretty much we haven't
seen anything that should lead us to
think that things are working uh are not
working
where can that come from
and that comes from and i think this is
the the point i wanted to highlight here
we don't know
who this pet bed is intended for
sometimes you're lucky and you work in
an environment like i said where you
know a lot about your customers but
sometimes it's something that we will
never know because the customers don't
tell us it's the same bed for cats and
dogs i don't know who the customer is
buying it for
and what happened in the background
so this is again a possible explanation
where we had a 50-50 split in our
population with with cat owners and dog
owners
in general when we tested the new design
what happened cat owners loved the new
the new bed they really really loved it
dog owners
not so much actually they didn't like it
a lot
again like i said this is underneath the
surface something that wouldn't never be
observable for us unless we actually go
and run some questionnaires but that's
not as effective
and what happened under the surface like
i said without us knowing
some subsection of some segment of the
population really liked what we had to
offer another one didn't so much but
overall we had an improvement
and then three months later
for whatever reason we now have more dog
owners coming to our website and
conversion drops
right and this is again simple
mathematics the slide will be available
if you want to check me on the under
arithmetics here and please do um but
and i i can say something happen when i
say something happen it can really be
anything and it can be something like
seasonal changes it can be maybe during
covert people prefer to adopt dogs maybe
our marketing department did something
that now targets dog owners more than
more than cat owners a lot of things can
happen around so as you can see with all
the good intentions in the world
we actually ended up with a product
that's maybe
worse in a way
so
what went wrong here
there are basically two assumptions when
you're running an a b test that you need
to be at least worry about
one
is uniformity again it's this idea that
if i see a five percent change it is
uniform across all the segments in my
populations the one that i see and
especially the ones that i don't see
right that is a very strong assumption
and the second thing
the assumption that's never right is
that everything stays the same or the
things are stable because everything
changes right that's uh i think we've
known this since a while like 3 000
years now no
yeah close to two thousand two and a
half thousand years now we've we've
known that things change
um so um and if you get a mix of both of
these things
this is exactly what you would get you
can get very very dramatic changes to
the results even though everything was
designed and planned properly
so
as i said first and this is just a
single test for a single test
you can have changes to population to
demographics
other things i mentioned before changes
to the ecosystem maybe a new competitor
comes in and changes the competitive
landscape another reason to maybe kind
of think again about what you're doing
um and this can be again a very long
list of things and this is only for one
test
if you have multiple tests well i want
to go into these
these
one by one to get into a little bit
deeper into each one of them if you have
multiple tests
then you have even more disruption i
mentioned marketing before okay
marketing changed a strategy unbeknownst
to you right and suddenly you have a
different population coming in
maybe not just marketing maybe the
landing page change and you're working
on checkout maybe something about the
product page change and you're working
on um something that has to do with post
checkout situation so basically
everything upstream from you
by design will change over time right
and you need to be able to at least
account for it or at least handle it in
some way so that's one kind of
disruption
another kind of disruption that can
happen slightly different than just your
uh test results getting better or worse
you can also end up if you run this kind
of city if you are in this kind of
situation
you can theoretically at least end up in
a situation where in different parts of
the product you reach different
conclusions about similar things so
something that i've actually seen happen
um i think it was payment method sorting
where basically different parts of the
website were sorting payment methods in
a different way
which if you are a customer and you go
and you start looking for your method or
you have your preferences this can
create a very confusing experience and
again you can take it into features you
can take it into a lot of other things
last but not least a little pet peeve of
mine i would say
i call it the product flux or the
slippery a
i hear from companies sometimes very
proudly and maybe justly so um you know
every single one of our users is at
least part of some kind of test at any
given point in time
and then my question to them is back
back
my my question back is okay so what is
your product and exactly at any given
time your product is basically changing
and it's almost a curse in a sense of
the tech domain especially of software
that we can change everything everywhere
all at once have if you haven't seen the
movie it's a really good one um
we can actually do that whereas if you
look at something like um
if you look at something like medicine
research or biotech
you would usually if you are recruiting
patients for example for trial you would
usually try to recruit patients that are
not part of another trial because that
can really disrupt your baseline right
that can be very damaging to what you're
doing um so usually try to recruit
patients that come from this let's say
status quo
um industry industrial design usually
there are some limitations either from
physics or from you know the industrial
process or it just tends to be a little
bit more rigid it's harder to change
machines and in software we can kind of
do whatever you want right we can change
things all the time
and if it is something that you really
need to do let's talk later about
bandits and what you can do with that
maybe a testing is not exactly what you
should be doing um but maybe there are
other ways to handle this because and
again think about the problem where it's
not just that the product changes over
time you run an experiment
over let's say a month which is you know
again depending on the volume you have
might not be a very you know a very big
experiment you run an experiment over a
month in that month
your a versus b is not the same a versus
b that you had at the beginning of the
experiment so this can create a lot of
disruption to the results you're getting
right
so
and this is how you end up and i'm sure
we've all seen this
a lot of products that kind of look like
this
like i said i think it's a more typical
situation in the software world where
you can really change a lot of things
and i'm not even going into the the
whole discussion about uh p-value uh
what's called the p-value random walk um
and which statistical method can lead
you in a better way and a worse way you
can even with the best intentions you
can end up in a situation like this
i promised for machine learning
engineers
what do you care about this is a b
testing i know we we know about you know
we know about feature drift
it is a problem so like i said all the
problems i described to you about
stability about changes about testing
something or even your product your
model against another alternative in
production as production is changing
over time same problem as before
you can look at it as some form of
feature drift those of you are familiar
with the term the idea is again that
your input changes over time so you need
to adjust for this
same problems that you have with
upstream data same problem that you have
with other decisions in the product and
same problems that you have again
different
models can end up with different
recommendations or different
optimizations for the same user in
different areas of the product it's very
easy to see that you know when marketing
pushes one thing but then pricing does
something a little bit different right
again this is something that can happen
a lot
i will say again
not not exactly not the topic for today
but if you are building if you really
want to build a good machine learning
model you do need to think about
some kind of randomization it's not
exactly a b testing but if you maybe
focus on some key features especially
the ones you're trying to influence and
basically consi take them as some form
of an a b test where you can actually
learn about causality um
it's a complicated thing to do you might
need to kind of decide exactly where you
want to focus and there are some ideas
i'll mention about like based on
adjustments where you can control things
but in general we are in the same world
of problems
now
and okay and again with machine learning
we've all seen these examples right
where um i want to say something like a
new kind of populations comes in and
suddenly your recommendation engine that
works 99 of the time work uh really
really well for that one percent of
users you end up being in some you know
a hacker news headline that oh my god
look at what this company recommended
for me how they are there so
again it is a problem
so what can you do as a data scientist
um
some really basic basic things and this
applies for a b testing and this applies
for uh machine learning models as well
monitor your features
even something as basic as just looking
at things every once in a while just to
make sure that they look the same you
know kind of the eyeball test
as humans who are really really good at
detecting these kind of changes where
sometimes you know automation doesn't
work that well
but at least make it accessible and and
part of your process
if you are working on
a lot of models on a lot of features you
can automate a lot of that process just
looking at differences
t-tests uh man with me whatever
statistical test is uh your favorite or
if you're looking distributions
colomogol smyrnov is a really really
smart idea and looking at kind of shifts
or let's say big shifts to your
distribution underlying distributions
it's a really nice way of doing that
if you are working again in a machine
learning world there are all kinds of
ideas of
the feature shift models
sorry
the feature shift models where if you
are working with a lot of variables you
can kind of try and figure out how
everything works together and where the
changes are coming from again not gonna
talk too much about them in this talk
but come and talk to me later if you
wanna if you wanna uh talk more about
this and the most important thing and i
know you've probably seen a lot of
solutions and ideas in this conference
in the last in yesterday and today talk
to your platform provider and try to
automate this because all of these are
things that are pretty simple to
automate alerts that are pretty easy to
set up and you can and should do that
for everything in your data
other things you can do
if you want to take a few steps further
maybe you're working in a narrower
domain where you don't have that many
features
you can actually build a model
even for you know when you're running an
a b test every test can also be kind of
analyzed as a way as a model where you
can try and understand how different
features influence different things and
that can help you to generalize if your
population changes a little bit at least
kind of at least for the things that you
know again if you know a lot of things
about your users and if you have that
kind of pretty good coverage you can use
that
same thing goes for causality and
upstream changes so again
something like again conversion model
and taking into account things like
marketing budget in your conversion
model might not be a bad idea
um and
if you can
at least in some domains coming from the
pricing world if you can isolate a few
variables where you are focused on
um
you can treat other variables
as things that you're not going to touch
and then there are all kinds of
approaches usually with some nice
techniques on on machine learning
methods and also logistic regressions if
you only want to do that where you can
kind of
on a periodical basis kind of adjust
just a baseline so there are ways to do
that as well without refitting the model
every single day if you're refitting
your model every single day again maybe
we should talk about bandits and come
come talk to me about bandits and maybe
we should we should uh that would be an
interesting discussion like why do you
need to refit every day
um
yep and so that's kind of those are ways
of doing it and basically the whole
notion of this comes from kind of
understanding causality right if we have
a good understanding of causality of
features if we're not working in a
problem that's huge and super or in an
environment that's huge and super
complicated it's something we can do
but what if we are what if things are
really complicated what if it's really
difficult to build these models or if we
have a lot of unknowns
another option which i've also seen
happening
i call it the ship of the damned
basically
an interesting idea if you can do it is
to keep a small percentage of your users
at any given time as i call it like the
eternal control group basically the
group that keeps getting the product
from maybe a year ago maybe even two
years ago depending how
how you evolved your product basically
think about it this way that there is a
baseline at any given time we develop
features and then kind of close another
version and every time we compare the
new kind of new vision of the product to
the old vision of the product so we have
to keep a small group of users on the
old vision of the product the whole time
business-wise this is something that
business you know business owners
sometimes have trouble uh digesting
because we are in a sense sacrificing
right something here this is where
testing is has a cost to it and that's
something that needs to be communicated
because if the new product is amazing
five percent will stay on the old
version that's not so amazing um
it's not something you can always do
especially if that's something there are
things like um
let's say reputation issues you know
users that complained that they didn't
get the latest feature from their
favorite social network and start
complaining about it and that creates a
problem right why are you discriminating
why am i getting a bad version
but sometimes you can do it
and that's a really really i want to say
a safe way of making sure that you can
compare to the writing right even if
something changed along the way you are
still comparing the new vision to the
old vision
you are not alone in this meaning that
the onus is not only a new newest data
scientist to manage this problem
something that i think pms also need to
understand and learn and if you're lucky
enough to work with a pm that
understands this it's a great thing um
that
think about testing in a sense as a
limited resources like i said if we're
going to test every single change to
every single color and every single test
to every single font will end with
thousands of tests oh that sounds great
right but
again we'll end up in the same situation
with the same problems we had before
it's sometimes on us as data scientists
to push the pms to think more about
complete visions maybe and test them
basically think about testing as a
resource or as a budget where you need
to spend it where you want to spend it
on the important things on the important
features that you want to test so think
about it not as a kind of maybe not as
an ongoing process maybe kind of slow it
down a little bit and think about
complete visions to test against one
another that's one way of again just
dealing with it from the organizational
perspective no changes to the process
itself um again
coordination communication
it has to it has to happen right
upstream changes um product owners need
to understand the impact of other
products on what they're doing so they
need to be able to again communicate and
at least prepare for that
and yeah like i said coordinate across
products across domains and
one thing i'm interested in
periodically
if you really made an important decision
or a core decision some significant
changes to your product periodically try
and revisit that somehow either with the
eternal control group or maybe something
else try to revert a feature back and
and do that um because i when i
mentioned before you know kind of if you
saw the beginning the first slide i saw
was a cycle right
just by raise of hands if you have had
that experience i'm curious how many of
you seen a case where again you tested
something new you adopted a new feature
and then let's say a year later you
retested it
in a way how many of you have seen that
happen
i think i see oh okay not a lot so i
think it's it's kind of typical a
typical thing that happens where we say
something is better okay it's better
check let's move forward right so if you
have big important decisions about your
products
it it is a good idea to sometimes
revisit them and at least have the
facilities to revisit them because like
i said if you don't you might be kind of
again
from if you talk about optimization you
might be
getting lost in this random walk into
this very local minima where actually if
you took a step back and looked at the
whole product as a concept you can
actually make something much better
again testing visions against visions
and with that
questions
[Applause]
yep
hello uh i'm interested to know uh how
do you do exactly the a b testing do you
use anything uh like a dedicated sas
like optimizely or how do you do it so
in shopify currently we use a kind of a
homespun solution there's an we
developed our own platform basically for
a b testing
so again it's a it's a whole platform as
uh either the engineers can inject the
events basically inject events the fire
you know the assignment and and that
controls also the the assignment the
allocation and everything um yeah so we
have our own uh in shopify there's a
homebuild solution okay one more uh how
do you see the ais ml going hand-in-hand
with the abe testing because since you
have a lot of data and
you can have even multivariate testing
how can you take advantage of
the previous experiments to
to let the
ml itself
doing this
so
there are a few a few kind of i would
say a few a few topics here
i think
one
sorry one of them is um like i said
causality which
there is a lot of work about this in ml
right now i want to say it's it's really
cool that again being
coming from from statistical background
i have sometimes uh it's sometimes funny
to me that um ml papers rediscover
really deep insight from the 50s in
econometrics that happen sometimes about
causality
but
coming so so
if you can have some structure of
causality
you can like i said before bring in
information from other parts of the
product upstream information basically
right and integrate that into your model
so
if then there is a population change
right because of marketing spend so and
your model can support that
then your model at least should
extrapolate
up to some point right
it's it's a difficult thing you might
need to again retrain your model this is
why we train our models right every
every period so every every time but um
you can actually make the model more
flexible
in the sense that if you get upstream
information your model will be able to
extrapolate better better right for new
situations
at least should
the other thing i think i can talk about
in terms of machine learning is like you
said the multivariate drift
and here it's very similar it's this
concept again i'm not going to elaborate
too much but in a way it's a very
similar concept to propensity scores
the idea is that you look at the data
before and the data after you kind of
treat it as two different groups
and if you can
kind of find or explain one of the
difference in the if you find a
significant difference in the before and
after and you can explain it from one of
the using one of the features that is
what has changed right and again there
are all kinds of thoughts about like
randomizing the assignment and
everything you can you can do all kinds
of tricks there that will make the make
this more informative but basically
that's the idea so not just looking at
once
one feature and saying okay
age has changed the average age has
changed but you can also look at age
income and other things and say okay
if you have a good causal model there
and you can say that actually the change
is actually because we are now targeting
higher income or lower income or a
different
geography where age is different and
that is the cause of the change right to
the future set
so and then that also goes back to which
part of the model maybe you want to
retrain or if you need to retrain
another part of the model because if
it's something that we want to influence
versus something that we can't influence
there's a lot of things to say there
yeah
okay anymore
hi you mentioned uh having a kind of
bayesian approach
so when you do a b testing are you using
a bayesian test or using more like a p
value
so in shopify i think we went all we
kind of went all the way i think you
could well the platform supports
everything but i think a lot of the at
least we made sure that the defaults
would be uh some kind of a bayesian
approach
um
it's it's all the problems i mentioned
here i think also exist with a bayesian
approach
especially and maybe maybe other other
problems where again it depends on your
prior depends how you set it up there
are a lot of a lot of things to say
there
but it's definitely better than a
p-value in a sense right p-value
i have a lot to say about p-values um
especially that they don't usually don't
mean what you think they mean or if you
if you do know what they mean then they
sound really really bizarre
um and they can and have been shown to
lead to exactly that what we call the
random value sorry the random random
walk right over different uh hypothesis
so that that can happen there
um bayesian a b testing is basically you
just need to set up your prior
right it's um you know a very simple
univariate regression so you can set it
up this way
and oh just to mention that and then
if you do have a model and you do want
to impose causality that is something
that you can do very efficiently
with the bayesian model so that's
actually really great
okay
any more questions
hi thanks for the talk um
i
i really like the idea
with the eternal baseline but i wonder
whether you're
having running at risk to
actually eliminate randomization because
initially you can say okay we randomly
assign guys to either this eternal
control group or another group
but then they're stuck for 10 years with
this old software
and
on all subsequent a b tests they will
not be randomized anymore and the other
issue might be that after 10 years the
age might be
higher than with the experimental group
so if you are doing it like you said
it's not like you
take a group of people and say from now
on
if you look at it from a
in inflow outflow perspective
right
then you need to look at new users and
assign you
five percent of your new users to that
control group every day
every single one that comes in needs to
go through this randomization and five
percent of new business existing
business has to sit in that control
group and then at least the demographics
should should be
right very similar
um everything that happens after that
you're right in a sense that um for
example attrition will be higher there
probably maybe if you're doing the right
things
sometimes not that's you know you also
something discovered they actually like
it better but uh um so it's something
that you should be able to again if you
if you continuously assign people to
that group it's fine
um
i wouldn't go with 10 years
going back
like i said i think
you can do that and i know some in some
uh again going back to pricing uh
sometimes you just have you know price
list versus some kind of personalized
prices or recommendations you know kind
of standard products versus some
personalized recommendations right you
can you can kind of do play around with
that and that kind of stays very stable
over time um if it comes to a more
complicated product or something where
you can't just keep an old version all
the time
like i said i think a better strategy
would be to think about like these grand
or bigger visions
where
you get to a vision people stay in that
vision
a group of five percent will stay with
vision one you keep building it building
it until you decide okay this is the new
vision of the product you know maybe you
actually we learn something even
publicly and then everybody goes to the
next one and then again again and again
you kind of just lag them behind kind of
one major version in a way again
versions don't exist anymore right we're
all doing ci cd so
so that don't exist but at least some
kind of a vision that exists there and
then if you can just keep them at a lag
thank you
thanks for the talk i have a question
follow-up
so you say it for this keeping a small
part of your traffic on the vision one
and
iterating on version two for like two
years
like that means that your code base
still need to be handled version one and
every new thing on version two and i
think admit it can make i mean slower
down the overall platform because you
you need to change data and things like
that
and
so
absolutely true again
i think maybe years is not again
especially for software years would not
be the horizon
the time frame i would be thinking of
maybe months even less than that you
know depending how quickly you change
things
although
again to be honest like i said if
the message is that we need to change we
need to you know we're rolling with the
punches we change everything everywhere
all the time every day if you look at
the website a month ago it's going to be
very different
maybe we don't need to do a b testing
maybe we need to do something else
which is much more complicated and and
like i said in terms of maintaining
multiple versions multiple even back
ends sometimes that that's even next
level
and some companies do that
but um i would say again if you can
it is true it is a very good point and
this is where like i said there is a
cost
testing doesn't come without a cost at
all there is a cost and that might be
one of those costs that you need that
you need to understand and as a pm as a
product manager you need to at least
take into account like i said maybe not
two years back that seems to be a little
far for software but uh maybe a few
months back
hi thanks for the talk very interesting
um
so this is more a kind of philosophical
question somehow
and it's that so it seems that a b
testing forces you to only evolve
through
incremental changes right so your own
in other words uh you could not find the
iphone by iv testing the imax right so
so my my question is how do you deal
with that and uh because i mean they add
value av testing adds value but in the
long run right it seems so yeah thanks
i want to say that's maybe a separate
talk um in shopify uh we do a lot of
pilots for example there are other ways
of doing this and in general
a b testing and this is something that
you know
again i think it's data scientists maybe
we have a clear understanding of this
pms sometimes needs need some education
that this is not a replacement for
having a vision right
and
we can look kind of micro manage small
features test this or this or this but
at the end if you don't take that step
forward and look at a complete thing to
make sure that it makes sense
that's um
that's that's on us as data scientist
maybe to stop this but that's actually
also the responsibility of other people
on the team right to make sure and this
is why i mentioned i like the the
thinking of like think about visions
rather than on features
and if you are testing visions if you
can by the way again
some this this there are problems for
example especially if you're very public
like
marketing language right or marketing
campaigns that can work if they're
individualized but public marketing
campaigns in general you can't really do
even a b testing there right so they're
deploying also like i said if you are
really
testing something that's brand new
i yeah incrementally i wouldn't get
there this is where i would think more
of pilots and there is a whole different
topic about how you can learn from them
and generalize from them but that's a
type of thing
[Applause]
you